INTRO:
Just 8 years ago, Exxon was the most valuable
company in the world boasting a peak market
cap of $446 billion.
But since then, Exxon has slowly slipped down
the list.
First, they lost the number 1 spot, then they
dropped out of the top 10, and now they’ve
tumbled all the way down to number 33 with
a market cap of $259 billion.
That means that Exxon is officially over ten
times behind the new market leader Apple.
To make things worse, Exxon has struggled
to regain profitability over the past year,
and to top it all off, Exxon was kicked out
of the Dow Jones last year.
The Dow Jones is a combination of the top
30 American companies that hit a set of guidelines,
and Exxon had been part of this list for 92
years.
Yet, it looks like hitting a 100 years in
the Dow simply wasn’t in the cards for Exxon.
At first glance, it’s easy to attribute
this fall to the rise of EVs, but EVs only
account for 3% of global car sales.
So, even though an EV takeover is inevitable,
EVs aren’t really the ones eating into Exxon’s
top and bottom lines today.
In fact, Exxon would likely be in a very similar
situation even if it wasn’t for EVs, so
here’s what happened to the oil king that
dominated the businessworld for nearly a century.
FALLING OIL PRICES:
Taking a look back, the most obvious factor
behind Exxon’s fall is of course crashing
oil prices.
When your entire business is based on oil,
you’re basically screwed if oil takes a
nosedive, and that’s exactly what happened
between 2014 and 2016.
Within those two years, oil prices plummeted
from $120 per barrel down to just $40 per
barrel.
This flash crash was caused by a handful of
factors most of which Exxon had no control
over.
First of all, the US dollar was popping off
against the Euro, and given that commodities
are generally quoted in USD, a strengthening
dollar meant falling commodity prices.
In the meantime, China was actively trying
to do the exact opposite by devaluing the
yuan in 2015.
You see, China likes to maintain a weak currency
on purpose, and while that might sound stupid,
there is reason behind the madness.
When you have a weak currency, it’s easier
for foreigners to afford your exports which
increases exports.
At the same time, it also becomes harder for
citizens to afford imported items which reduces
overall imports.
While this is a good thing for China, this
was terrible for Exxon given that China is
the world’s largest oil importer.
All of a sudden, Exxon had substantially less
revenue from Americans and the Chinese, and
to make things worse, the middle eastern oil
giants would screw over Exxon as well.
Given the reduced demand for oil, it would’ve
been a smart move for OPEC to decrease oil
production.
Now, a lot of you would argue that decreasing
production is an unethical way to prop up
prices, but from their side it would’ve
been smart.
But, they decided not to reduce oil production
which led to a surplus in oil which further
drove down prices.
And the nail in the coffin was the Iran nuclear
deal which allowed Iran to start exporting
oil again.
It’s not clear how much of an impact this
additional supply actually had, but the threat
itself was enough for investors to flee oil.
All of these factors combined led to Exxon’s
revenue crashing over 50% from $440 billion
down to $205 billion.
But falling oil prices was just a taste of
what was to come.
NEGATIVE OIL PRICES:
Usually, with any investment, the worst case
scenario is just losing everything you put
in.
Unless you’re shorting a stock, the worst
case scenario is just 0.
But, with oil prices things went beyond zero
when oil prices literally went negative.
No one really expected how quickly the pandemic
could shut down the world and decrease oil
demand to nearly 0.
So, it’s not surprising that producers and
refiners were left with large amounts of excess
oil once the pandemic hit.
The problem though is that you can’t just
throw the oil into some reserves and try to
sell it once demand recovers.
Oil giants already had hundreds of tankers
carrying millions of barrels worth oil to
their destinations.
But once they reached their destination, customers
no longer wanted the oil, so they literally
had millions of barrels of oil just floating
around in the ocean doing nothing.
And every day these tankers were just sitting
around, loads of money was being burned.
It was just a matter of time until someone
broke and paid someone to simply take away
the oil, and that’s exactly what happened
on April 20, 2020.
In just one day, crude oil futures fell 306%
from $18.27 to negative $37.63.
And just when you think things can’t get
any worse, Saudi Arabia and Russia decide
to have a price war.
Common sense would tell you that when oil
prices are plummeting and even going negative,
it’s a good time to heavily reduce or even
halt oil production.
Yet, Saudi Arabia and Russia decided to do
the exact opposite.
Both of them knew that the other was losing
money, and so, they tried to basically run
each other out of business.
Eventually, they did come to a truce, but
not before pumping up OPEC oil output to 30
year highs when prices were literally negative.
Anyway, Exxon wasn’t the leading voice behind
the 2014 oil crash, the pandemic, or negative
oil prices, but they got obliterated in the
crossfire.
Now, nothing we’ve discussed so far is specific
to Exxon, and all oil companies were hurt
by these events.
But unlike Exxon and Shell, oil companies
like Chevron have almost fully recovered.
In fact, Chevron is only 10 to 15% away from
all time highs, and they never got kicked
from the Dow Jones.
So, clearly, a lot of the blame has to be
placed on Exxon as well.
UNWISE INVESTMENTS:
Probably the easiest loss Exxon could’ve
avoided was making outsized bets on the oil
industry.
Even though EVs haven’t made a big dent
in the overall oil industry yet, it’s just
a matter of time, and investing heavily into
oil ventures is plain stupid.
But, that’s exactly what Exxon has been
doing over the past decade.
In 2009, they spent $41 billion buying XTO
energy.
In 2012, they spent $2.6 billion buying Celtic
Exploration.
In 2017, they spent another $2.5 billion acquiring
InterOil.
And that same year, they spent another $6.6
billion to buy the Bass Family’s Permian
assets.
Aside from making acquisitions left and right,
Exxon has also been investing heavily into
their own business.
As recent as January 2020, the CEO of Exxon,
Darren Woods, announced that Exxon would be
investing $30 billion into exploration projects
in 2020 alone.
And the plan was to spend $30 to $35 billion
every year through 2025.
Unfortunately for Exxon, all of these poor
investments are only starting to bite back
after a decade.
For the longest time, Exxon didn’t want
to admit that these were bad investments.
They insisted that these investments just
needed time to recover, and they refused to
value these assets below what they paid for
them.
But recently, Exxon has been getting sued
for overvaluing their assets and misleading
investors.
Exxon finally gave in at the end of 2020,
and wrote off the $41 billion XTO investment
as a $20 billion loss.
And this right here is what really killed
Exxon in 2020.
Even during the height of the pandemic, Exon
was only losing half a billion to $1 billion
per quarter.
But after writing off this loss in the last
quarter of 2020, Exxon posted a $20 billion
loss.
And that marked the end of Exxons first unprofitable
year in 40 years.
Exxon isn’t in the clear yet either, there’s
still multiple ongoing lawsuits accusing Exxon
of overvaluing their other assets.
So, last year’s painful write down may just
be the first of many.
DIVIDEND LEGACY:
Moving onto Exxon’s other big money drain,
we have their dividend payments.
One of the defining characteristics of Exxon
stock is their flawless history of dividend
payments.
Exxon has literally never missed a dividend
payment in their history.
Standard Oil began paying a dividend in 1882,
and Exxon has kept up the tradition ever since
the break up.
This means that Exxon didn’t miss a payment
through world war 1, the great depression,
world war 2, the inflation crisis, the 1973
oil crisis, the dotcom bubble, the financial
recession, and of course the pandemic.
This places Exxon in an elite group of stocks
called dividend aristocrats who not only never
miss a payment, but continuously increase
their payments.
It’s not always super easy to pay a dividend
though especially a high yielding dividend.
Over the past few years, Exxon has been forced
to borrow money to pay out their dividends,
and while that’s super irresponsible, at
this point, a lot of Exxon’s leadership
would rather file for bankruptcy than miss
a dividend payment.
And I don’t blame them.
If they missed a dividend payment, not only
would they ruin a 140 year streak that’s
virtually impossible to rebuild, but they
would give up one of the only things that’s
still going for Exxon.
Exxon may be going bankrupt over the next
decade, but one thing many investors are still
extremely confident in is that Exxon will
pay dividends till the very end.
And if Exxon were to miss a payment right
now, that would simply destroy investor trust
and drive the stock price even lower, at least
in the short term.
With that being said though, paying out a
massive dividend given the company’s situation
is extremely irresponsible, and it’s objectively
holding back the company.
BLEAK FUTURE:
Looking into the future, it’s not clear
where Exxon is headed.
In terms of financials, Exxon is nearly back
to pre-pandemic profit levels on a quarterly
basis.
But, the thing to keep in mind is that the
pandemic wasn’t what hurt Exxon the most,
it was actually writing down that $20 billion
investment loss.
And given that Exxon has plenty of other such
investments, it’s very possible that they
continue to incur such losses over the next
decade.
In the meantime, Exxon refuses to embrace
renewable energy.
Exxon is actually currently being investigated
for spreading disinformation regarding climate
change and downplaying its effect.
When questioned in court, the CEO, Darren
Woods, of course denied these allegations.
But whether Exxon was spreading disinformation
or not, their stance on the future is crystal
clear.
Darren Woods has repeatedly reiterated that
climate change does not pose any long term
threats to the oil industry.
In my opinion, this viewpoint is fundamentally
flawed as the transition to renewable energy
has little to do with climate change.
Now, don’t get me wrong here, switching
to renewable energy will help with combating
climate change, but climate change is not
what’s pushing the transition itself.
The primary factor that will move the needle
in my opinion is electric options being more
convenient, easier to maintain, and most importantly
cheaper.
Once these demands are met, companies and
people will switch to renewable options regardless
of whether they believe in climate change
or not.
Now, it’s not like this change is gonna
happen overnight and Exxon is about to go
bankrupt next year.
But, the longer Exxon chooses to ignore this
trend, the more likely it is that they’ll
end up like Texaco.
But that’s just what I think.
Do you guys think Exxon has a future?
Comment that down below.
Also, drop a like if you’re glad that the
era of oil giants is coming to an end.
And of course, consider joining our discord
community to suggest future video ideas and
consider subscribing to see more questions
logically answered.